they maybe loveth intelligent
civilizations capable of communicating
us in impact on ourselves of contact
with another intelligent civilization is
now being discussed by serious thinkers
the world over but seemed to me just
perfectly natural that we would not be
the only manifestation of of life in the
cosmos we now know without a doubt that
the possibilities for life are literally
innumerable and we haven't begun to look
we have way more places still to go
so we take very large telescopes and we
point them at nearby stars or nearby
galaxies and look for that special kind
of radio signal that we think is only
produced by technology it's time to
commit to finding the answer to search
for life beyond Earth we are live we are
intelligent we must know
[Music]
we are literally doing an experiment to
find out what the answer is rather than
doing what we've done for millennia
which is to ask the priests and the
philosophers what we should believe
about life beyond Earth
dr. Jill tarter is part of a movement
known as SETI the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence she's
dedicated her life to it she's also the
inspiration behind Jodie Foster's
character in the sci-fi movie contact
[Music]
seems like an awful waste of space today
SETI is a mission involving scientists
from around the world
so what SETI searches look for is
electromagnetic radiation like radio
light that is different than the radio
signals that we get from natural objects
like stars and galaxies and quasars
and consistent with the kind of light or
electromagnetic radiation that's
produced by technology
Andrew Simeon heads up a team at the
University where up to 8.8 petabytes a
great Bank right for ten years they will
be scanning the cosmos as part of a
hundred million dollar privately funded
initiative technological sources have a
very interesting property which is that
they can compress electromagnetic energy
in time or in frequency so you can have
a lot of energy a lot of radio energy at
just one place on the radio dial and
that's something that Nature doesn't
tend to do the team's work is the most
comprehensive search ever undertaken in
nearly six decades of SETI efforts and
technological advances mean that the
search is finally building momentum what
we've done for a number of years is to
go to a large radio telescope presumably
a national facility and rent time or
figure out a way to piggyback on other
people's observations and so we wanted
to get to a situation where we were
doing SETI 24/7
290 miles northeast of San Francisco is
the Allen telescope a cluster of small
dishes dedicated in large part to SETI
research the Allen telescope array is
the first time we've ever built a large
radio telescope out of a lot of small
dishes the joy of having small dishes is
that they look at a large area on the
sky all at once ultimately we'd like to
have 350 of these six meter dishes here
right now we have 42
alongside more telescopes more powerful
computers offer a chance to expand the
search the quantity of data produced is
staggering with our next generation of
radio telescopes we'll be ingesting as
much data from just one telescope as is
coursing through the entire Internet at
any given second so we collect a massive
amount of data from the telescopes that
we observe with and some snippets of
that data are actually brought back to
our lab here at Berkeley there's this
like gradual roll we actually have to
look for the sorts of signals that we're
trying to find and to do that we develop
powerful algorithms including algorithms
that use things like machine learning
and artificial intelligence scientists
now know that most stars have planets
Jill tarter believes this radically
increases the chances life is out there
[Music]
when I was a graduate student we knew
about nine planets those in our solar
system but we didn't know about planets
around other stars not at all today we
know that there are more planets out
there than stars every star has on
average at least one planet and usually
more so that is a huge game-changer the
universe seems a lot more potentially
bio-friendly and now lots of people are
interested in the question of life
beyond Earth
there are more stars and grains of sand
on all the beaches in the world if you
look at one of these grains of sand and
say that's the Sun and the third planet
around its habitable and you look at the
beach I mean how could it happen in one
grain of sand and not in others so we're
very optimistic about SETI it's probably
just a matter of us being able to
recognize what a very advanced
civilization would look like Lawrence
Doyle was part of the NASA team used the
Kepler space telescope to hunt for
planets outside our solar system but now
he's bringing the search back down to
earth there are various kinds of
intelligence but the one that SETI is
going to detect is going to be
communication intelligence everything
communicates all animals and even plants
communicate it's just a matter of how
complex is that communication I thought
well why aren't we studying non-human
communication on earth so as a proxy for
an extraterrestrial signal we proposed
starting with bottlenose dolphins and
humpback whales and squirrel monkeys to
kind of design an intelligence filter
for SETI so that we can recognize the
general rules of intelligence so we've
devised various ways of looking at a
signal a message and analyzing how
complex what the relationships are
between signals in human linguistics the
relationships are called syntax if
you're missing a word you can recover it
if you're missing two words in a row you
can still recover three you can see it
gets harder if you go up to nine there's
still a possibility you could fill in
those words but there's very low
connection you for missing ten words you
might as well just guess a word from the
dictionary so we go up to ninth order
entropy that is there are still
connections nine words away of grammar
and syntax all animals all people all
extraterrestrials they have to follow
these rules if they're transmitting
knowledge to each other
and if and when we get a message we can
recognize the complexity of that
communication system we can say okay we
go up to 9th order entropy word entropy
squirrel monkeys probably go up to 2nd
order i'll humpback whales we don't know
yet we haven't got enough data
extraterrestrial signal comes in and
they go up to not 20th order entropy and
we are gonna know that their
communication system is to ours as ours
as the squirrel monkeys we are connected
to this huge cosmos and we want to know
what else might have evolved out there
were we to know for sure that the
universe actually many many times has
given rise to some sort of organism like
us that thinks and ask questions about
the universe itself I think it could
very much change our our perspective on
science and our perspective as humans
and I think the ultimate outcome of that
change in in perspective could be truly
truly amazing indeed
[Music]
you
[Music]